-Tig, it's great to see you.
-It's great to see you.
-Yeah, I'm happy you're here.
I have a lot of things to talk
to you about and ask you about.
-Great.
That's what I'm here for.
[ Laughter ]
-I have one thing I want to ask
you about.
You were recently on a celebrity
"Wheel of Fortune."
Do you remember this?
-I do.
-Yeah.
-You had to answer this puzzle.
I'm going to show it
to everyone.
-Okay.
-I don't know how this story
ends really.
This is the puzzle.
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
-That was a puzzle.
-Yes. Now, that's -- So you --
"Crashing my..."
-Do you want to know
what I said?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
It must be
"crashing my exercise bike."
-Um, well...
[ Laughter ]
-Let's see what you said.
-Tig?
-Crashing my exor...cist bill?
[ Buzzer ]
Can we edit my guess out?
"Crashing my exorcist bill."
That is the answer.
I'm not going to be humiliated
on national television.
-It's too late for that.
-Now, what was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
-What was going through your --
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
What was going through your head
at the moment?
-Well, I mean -- Well, first of
all, I was thinking,
"I never imagined I'd be on
'Wheel of Fortune.'"
-Yeah.
-Second of all, I was thinking,
"I don't imagine
I'll be very good at this."
[ Laughter ]
And then third, I was like,
"Well, I'm correct."
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't think it was --
Or were you just being funny?
You're just being -- No.
-No, I --
[ Laughter ]
-You really thought it was
"exorcist bill."
-I really was like --
-You're nervous?
-I wasn't nervous.
I was -- You know, I was wrong.
[ Laughter ]
I was just wrong.
[ Cheers and applause ]
These people are --
-I feel like these things happen
to you.
These funny things happen
I think you're a magnet for
funny things that happen.
And this is another example.
This is an article that was
on Buzzfeed.
It says, "an Airbnb host
complained about their booking
being low and people responded
with a list of reasons why they
refused to use the service,"
Airbnb.
And there's just a photo of you
last time you were on our show.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know anything about this
or...?
-No. Your producer showed this
to me.
And I guess -- I don't know why
Buzzfeed --
I guess if you work for
Buzzfeed, let us know why...
why you chose this terrible
photo of me.
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, actually,
a similar thing happened to me.
[ Laughs ]
People were tagging me
about my birthday --
on my birthday on social media.
It was like, "Oh, happy birthday
to comedian Tig Notaro."
And it was a picture of
Rosie O'Donnell.
[ Laughter ]
And I was just like, "What?
They just like --
It's like, 'oh, national lesbian
birthday'?"
[ Laughter ]
And just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is that a thing?
-They just Google, like,
any lesbian with short hair.
And they're like, "That's fine."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Whatever."
Just Melissa Etheridge.
[ Laughter ]
Anybody -- She doesn't have
short hair, but anyway.
-Can we talk about your new --
You're a movie star now.
-I am.
-Yeah.
-I've actually been a movie star
for a while.
-Yeah, that's true.
For a while now.
-For a while.
-Are you enjoying the fame?
-I enjoy my level of fame
because...
Well, I guess there's a downside
because I --
You know, I do stand-up and I'll
tour around the country.
I did a 70-city tour last year.
And sometimes, I knock on
the back door of the theater,
and security won't let me in.
[ Laughter ]
-And you're playing there
that night?
-Yeah. I'm there that night.
And they're like, "Uh, yeah?"
And I'm like, "Oh, I'm
performing at the show."
-"At the show here tonight."
[ Laughter ]
At your show.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. And I have to -- I have to
explain that I am
the big sensation that sold out
the theater.
-Yeah. Well, got to kind of keep
you humble.
Got to keep you moving,
on your toes.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, because you can't let
this movie star status
go to your head.
-I know. And just having
my birthday wishes have
Rosie O'Donnell's face, like --
[ Laughter ]
-I want to talk about this
movie, "Your Place or Mine."
We just had Ashton Kutcher
on the show yesterday.
He was singing your --
-He's a dream boat.
-Singing your praises.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's you, Ashton Kutcher,
Reese Witherspoon.
This is exactly a rom-com
that I want to watch.
-Yes.
-That I want to see.
What's it like being in
a rom-com with these two?
-Well, it's really fun.
And they're both so great.
I will say it was a little
alarming to watch the movie
because during the filming, I'm
thinking, "Oh, this is so great.
Everybody's so nice and fun."
And then I'm watching
the actual movie,
and these two people are
so attractive, Reese and Ashton.
And I'm not --
Look, I'm not hard on myself.
But I will say it was alarming.
You see these beautiful Ashton
and Reese faces on screen,
and I play their friend.
And I come around a corner,
and I was startled.
[ Laughter ]
I look like I'm the same age
as Yoda.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-What?
No.
-No. Wait.
Listen. And I'm truly --
I'm not hard on myself.
But I was like [Gasps]
"Oh, my gosh."
I mean, we have very different,
you know, night lotion regimen.
What do you --
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what's going on.
But I was just like, "Whoa!"
-How do we set up the movie?
-How do we set it up?
-Yeah.
-Well, it's a rom-com.
-Yep.
-Starring Reese Witherspoon...
[ Laughter ]
...Ashton Kutcher and Yoda --
-No --
[ Laughter ]
Alright, alright, alright.
It's very funny. And I want to
show everyone a clip.
Here's Tig Notaro
and Reese Witherspoon
in "Your Place or Mine."
Take a look at this.
-Have you been looking at
her Instagram?
-You think I'm not gonna be
looking at
Jimmy's girlfriend's
Instagram account?
I mean, what are we even doing?
Who would I even be?
-Look, it's fine. It works
for him. It works for me.
And besides, Jack loves hanging
out with Scarlet.
-Alright. Well, I hope that you
get what you want
out of this trip.
-Yes.
-And what you need.
You know, get your degree,
find a man, come home.
And then remodel that
ancient kitchen of yours.
I also think it's time to get
layers in your hair.
Layers, but not bangs.
Bangs are for an emergency.
-That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tig Notaro.
"Your Place or Mine" begins
streaming this Friday
on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with a performance
from Fitz and the Tantrums.
Stick around!